hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast darpa's brain function
portfolio i am brenda kelly kim labrutz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this presentation has
been approved for a category one
continuing medical education credit by
loma linda university if you are
interested in obtaining cmes after
attending this presentation
please click on the get your free cme ce
credits button
in the bottom left corner of the event
screen
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event
you can submit questions by typing them
in the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems
viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right
of your presentation
window or submit your problem through
the green q a button lower left
i would now like to introduce our
speaker dr justin sanchez
dr sanchez joined dso as a program
manager in 2013. before coming to darpa
dr sanchez was an associate professor of
biomedical engineering and neuroscience
at the university of miami and a faculty
member of the miami project of cure
paralysis
he directed the neuroprosthetics
research group where he oversaw
development of the neural interface
medical treatments and neurotechnology
for treating paralysis and stroke and
for deep brain stimulation for movement
disorders tourette syndrome and
obsessive-compulsive disorder
he has published more than 75
peer-reviewed papers hold seven patents
in neuroprosthetic design and offered a
book on the design of brain machine
interfaces
dr sanchez holds doctor of
philosophy and master of engineering
degrees in biomedical engineering and a
bachelor of science degree in
engineering science
all from the university of florida
we'll now turn it over to dr sanchez for
his presentation
so thank you so much uh for the great
introduction there and it's a it's a
real pleasure uh to give a presentation
to all of you today
uh we're living an extremely exciting
time
we have international efforts
that are just ramping up and ongoing in
the area of brain science and
neurotechnology and it's just an
extraordinary uh period of time to be
thinking about the function of the brain
and the potential for the brain again
moving into the future
uh one of my goals for the the talk
today is to give everybody an update on
the work that we're doing at darpa as a
part of our brain function research
portfolio
um so as you can see from the screen
here you're not going to have any slides
and i just like to give some remarks on
some of the uh the work that's ramping
up and uh and how we're going about that
work okay so just to uh to get started
here
the portfolio programs that i'm managing
is in support of president obama's brain
initiative again this was a
effort that was kicked off in in 2013
and
multiple federal agencies are
collaboratively working to deliver upon
some of the goals of president obama's
brand initiative
now uh one aspect that we feel very
strongly about uh here at darpa is the
connection between the promise of the
brain initiative and the delivery of the
objectives of the brain initiative and
we're working extremely hard on the
delivery part about this so again it's
very easy to say uh we want to uh study
the brain it's going to
tackle some of the many challenges of
the brain but how do we actually get to
that delivery phase
and there are a couple key ideas that
are really going to help us move forward
on that and it consists of the following
aspects one is to seek out what we call
non-traditional insight and capabilities
in order to
see into the brain in a very different
way
you know one might think that you know
fundamental neuroscience uh is the only
way to go about addressing some of the
issues of the brain initiative and at
doorbot we say yes that is a
foundational science in a foundational
area that should be part of the brain
initiative but there are also other
areas you know other people and again
non-traditional areas that may be able
to provide insight
into the problems associated with the
brain initiative
uh the second component that we feel
very strongly about uh is this aspect we
really want to ensure that the
scientific conversations uh and
endeavors remain very relevant to the
public ultimately it's the taxpayer that
is uh supporting the brain initiative
and we need to make sure that everything
that we deliver back has uh you know
high relevance and high meaning uh to
the general society right so there's a
social contract that goes along with
doing this kind of work and we want to
make sure that we're not just doing
science for the sake of science but are
doing science in order to really again
give back to the people that are
ultimately supporting uh this effort
and then the third part that's extremely
important is that significant innovation
is needed in order to enable these new
opportunities and this really is kind of
boiled down to the hard work right it's
not just talking about the brain
initiative it's not just talking about
the brain brains actually doing that
fundamental science or doing that
fundamental technology transition in
order to make the kinds of things
available um
moving forward into the future so we're
pushing on all of those areas again
working really hard in order to
make those capabilities accessible to
people so they can do great work and
innovate in this space
now at darpa
the people that we serve
are military personnel darpa is a part
of the dod and whenever we think about
the brain or we think about uh
neuroscience with respect to the brain
uh we think about those military
personnel and all of the complex uh and
challenging situations um that that
military uh personnel face so again if
you think about all of the services that
are out there again the people that keep
our country safe know whether it's by
land uh by air or by sea uh these people
uh have to learn how to control very
complex systems uh they're under
extraordinary types of stress you know
stresses that many of us uh you know
have never experienced or uh probably
would never want to experience and you
know that makes their job very difficult
and then you know those military
personnel also subject to extraordinary
injury that results from the you know
very difficult job of protecting our
country
so you know we often think about brain
sciences and neurotechnology in that
kind of context and framework and think
about how we can again give back
to those people that again are living
with that stress and and are subject to
that extraordinary injury
um you know and and paying back the debt
to them in terms of their commitment to
serving the country so we always got to
keep that in mind again not just doing
science for the sake of science but
doing science to deliver capability to
the people that are ultimately serving
uh this great nation
so uh with that in mind you know let's
talk a little bit about the science okay
so uh there's a long history of
neuroscience of the brain of people been
been doing this kind of research for for
a long period of time and i'd just like
to highlight that there's a transition
happening today okay so as you saw
from the title of this presentation it's
about brain function research
and it's quite interesting that you know
when the original concepts were being
kind of tossed around with respect to
the brain initiative you know there's a
lot of talk about brain activity maps
okay like static maps
and um
that's interesting right that that um
that approach is out there and that
concept is out there but you know at
darpa we feel that you know the idea of
a map or an anatomic you know set of
structures is very much rooted in like
the early 1900s you know people are
working during that time to make
demarcations of in the brain
and uh and and trying to understand
at least where those demarcations are as
we kind of fast forward to kind of like
the late you know uh
1900s or even getting into the early uh
you know uh 20 2010 2011 2012 this folks
more like brain function research right
actively engaging the brain as it
interacts with the environment
developing tools for understanding the
dynamic interaction of the brain with
the environment and understanding the
ongoing production of neural activity in
both normal and abnormal situations like
with respect to disease so you're very
much focused on developing not only
tools
to understand or access this kind of
information but also
developing the techniques in order to
analyze those neural signals um and then
put them to good use whether it's for
restoration of function or even just
understanding how the brain processes
information in general okay so again
it's all about brain function research
and getting one of my goals of today is
to give everybody a highlight and
overview of uh the kinds of projects
that we're working on that are in this
brain function arena okay all right so
shifting gears here a little bit let's
talk about the the exact portfolio
uh of projects uh that we're working on
and they cover multiple domains and and
let me just give everybody a high level
um you know insight into those domains
okay so we talked about function the
first function that the agency was
really really interested in
is in the domain of movement and control
okay so many military personnel in
service of this nation uh are their
ability to move is affected right they
could be injured by a
spinal cord injury or they could be
injured in such a way that they lose a
limb and their ability to move is taken
away from them
and if you think about let's say for
example upper extremity issues right so
losing a arm
to amputation
for many
military personnel before darpa kind of
started doing this kind of work the best
solution that we had for them uh was a
metal hook a metal prosthetic hook
and at darpa you know we said this isn't
enough and we've got to do better we've
got to come up with a new technology a
new way of kind of thinking about uh
restoring movement
after injury so we developed a program
called revolutionizing prosthetics that
its mission was uh to develop a new
prosthetic system and again deliver uh
really remarkable control of that system
okay so that's one area we're going to
talk about today again the domain of
movement and control we've been very
successful in that domain
and it really sparked the next series of
things that i'm going to tell you about
and um and again it's an expanded
function so we have a new program that
just got off the ground very recently
it's called restoring active memory
uh and this uh the idea of this program
is develop prosthetic devices for the
restoration of memory function so uh
traumatic brain injury again military
personnel many of them suffer from it
and one of the functions that is lost
after a traumatic brain injury is memory
memory function so the ability to form
and recall memories so again we have
this new program in a memory neural
prosthetic is called a ram or restoring
active memory
kind of moving along here in terms of
our our portfolio the third area i'd
like to tell you a little bit about
today is in the neuropsychiatric domain
so again many military personnel suffer
with
suffer from and with a variety of
neuropsychiatric issues uh you know
ranging from ptsd to depression and
anxiety and pain and addiction and again
if we think about what are the available
treatments for neuropsychiatric illness
right now it's kind of you know go talk
to your therapist lay out on the couch
take some medications you know we think
that that's not enough those methods
while they can be effective in some uh
ways
may not be as precise as we ultimately
want so
we are looking at prosthetics in that
domain so developing closed loop neural
interfaces that can be capable of
treating or
affecting neuropsychiatric illness and
the name of the program associated with
this kind of work is called subnets all
right that stands for systems-based
neurotechnology for emerging therapies
we know that neuropsychiatric illness
not only affects one structure of the
brain but multiple sub networks of the
brain and that's why we called this
program with that name subnets because
it really kind of captures the idea that
is associated with building devices in
this domain
the last idea that i just like to share
with you is kind of part of our
full portfolio here is a program called
neurofast that stands for neuro function
activity structure and technology
and
compared to all of the other programs
that i've just described there the neuro
fast program changes the way that we
interface with the brain so again
compared to revolutionizing prosthetics
ram and the subnets program those are
all based in electrophysiology we know
that there are some limitations uh
related to electrophysiology
we can't capture simultaneously brain
structure
uh and activity
at the same time so we asked the
question can we develop a new program
that fundamentally changes the way that
we interface with the brain we're trying
to do that in the neuro fast program the
focus there is on developing optical
interfaces of the brain so again
fundamental approach you know change if
we use optical interfaces we may be able
to get both simultaneous brain structure
and brain activity again at the same
time from uh the same awake and behaving
uh animal okay
so um again that's an overview of our um
our
neurotechnology neuroscience
portfolio what i'd like to do next um is
is go into each one of those in a little
bit more detail and tell you about um
some of the work that we're doing there
um i do see one question here about
somebody asking are we moving through
this slide so again uh just a heads up
for everybody here that i'm just
providing remarks uh we are just having
this one title slide here and uh we're
just drilled down in a conversational
form uh on each one of these programs
okay all right so let's go through that
portfolio one by one let's start with
the revolutionizing prosthetics program
uh and let me tell you about some of the
advancements that have happened there so
again remember the fundamental problem
here was people that are living with
let's say upper extremity amputations
and the best that we could give to them
were metal hooks
as a solution to losing your upper arm
and we want to do much better than that
so the agency set out to develop next
generation kinds of prosthetic systems
we actually developed two arms one was
developed by deca this is dean cayman's
company the same person
that developed the segway we have a
remarkable arm system called uh um
it kind of has a nice name called the
luke arm uh it was just uh fda approved
uh in the last year so again it's really
remarkable darpa gets into this space
develops a really advanced prosthetic
arm system and we took it from concept
all the way to fda approval remarkable
thing about this arm system it has the
same size weight shape and grip strength
compared to a adult human uh arm
it's completely modular so if you need
just a hand we can give you a hand if
you need uh you know three quarters of
your arm we can give you three quarters
of your arm or if you need a full arm we
can also give you a full arm again the
system is completely modular and again a
prosthetist can prescribe any level of
arm that one
ultimately needs
uh the second arm system i like to tell
you about here was developed by the
johns hopkins university applied physics
lab this is a modular prosthetic limb
it's a little bit different compared to
the deck arms very dexterous uh and has
uh some more functionality in terms of
how it moves uh compared to that
compared to the deca arm system again
it's also completely modular again
depending upon your injury you can get
any level of prosthetic that you uh you
ultimately need
a remarkable aspect of both of these
armed systems is that since we got into
doing this kind of work
97 people have logged a combined 12 000
hours of user testing on these arm
systems and again this is remarkable
right you think about darpa as being
this agency is just kind of working in
these uh you know far off kind of spaces
revolutionizing prosthetics is a great
example of you know we set the bar
really high and went after a really
tough problem we developed physical arm
systems there's a lot of people that are
using those arm systems and a lot of
hours uh engage with those arm systems
and we hope to again continue to push
forward uh on those arm systems moving
into the future now
uh the way that we control those arms is
a variety of control modalities uh for
the deca arm that was approved by the
fda uh it's approved for using inertial
sensors to control the arm so again you
can put little sensors on your feet and
as you kind of move your feet around the
arm system will respond to that it also
can be driven by uh emg activity so
again putting little sensors on your
limbs and sensing uh when you're
contracting your muscles as a control
modality but one of the things that we
really push hard upon again this aspect
is not fda approved yet but is one of
the big demonstrations on the program
that we wanted near natural upper
extremity kind of control and we know
that if we really want that near natural
control you got to go directly back to
the brain so we created arm of the
program where you could implant a
microelectrode array into the primary
motor cortex and we had a few
individuals actually use their motor
cortex direct signals directly out of
their motor cortex
to actuate the arm systems and if you've
ever seen some of these videos that are
out there on the internet they're pretty
remarkable uh you know the the the
control is very natural you know person
can just describe how they're moving the
arm
no additional effort beyond uh imagining
controlling just your own natural arm so
again really remarkable
uh feat of science and technology and
have made a great progress there um
a few notes uh just about you know this
brain actuated control of the arm you
know there's a lot of people that were
working on rehabilitation science uh in
conjunction with this effort and uh you
know they've tried you know brain
actuation a variety of things
exoskeletons
uh have been trying to do kind of rehab
kind of techniques like boxing blocks
kinds of tasks and things like that so
again it really presents a new avenue of
rehabilitation and therapy for people
living with these kinds of injuries
um moving into the future of revolution
prosthetics you know there are a couple
areas that are really interesting uh you
know we really tried to push on the
robotic side of this of building some
intelligence into those robotics and
thinking about shared control between
the user's brain and the uh intelligent
robotics uh there's a lot of
opportunities there for uh for that kind
of work uh and again there are a few
people in the country uh kind of working
on these kinds of things
uh and then the last area that's uh it's
really um you know kind of uh bubbling
up to the top and kind of the last
milestone that we're trying to
achieve here is that everything i've
told you about right now has just been
on the motor side of things
we are working to instrument the
fingertips of our advanced arm systems
uh with force transducers such that we
can add the sensory component so again
uh technology didn't exist necessarily
to do this on these arm systems so
there's a hardware side that needs to be
built but then the secondary uh more
difficult side is can we put electrode
arrays in the primary sensory cortex
and provide uh inputs into the brain
that would allow somebody to perceive
the sense of touch through the arm
systems so that's the last milestone
that we're trying to achieve on that
program again working really hard uh to
achieve that uh working into the future
okay so that's revolutionizing
prosthetics uh program a lot of uh work
has uh has happened on that thus far
again a few uh last really big
challenges so stay tuned for um uh the
the new developments coming in in that
arena all right
so moving on here
like to talk about the next area of
brain function uh research that we're
working on you remember this progression
we're gonna going from motor control now
to memory restoration okay so uh again
neuroprosthetic control is very
interesting to darpa we think it's a
very new modality for interfacing with
the brain we're doing it for motor kinds
of systems but now the question becomes
for human subjects how do we develop
closed loop you know sensing and
stimulating of the brain to restore the
function to
form and recall memories again for
people living with traumatic brain
injury this is a huge problem
the um the kinds of options that are
available to
restore this function people living with
those disabilities are few and far
between so we're saying can we use
neurotechnology to ultimately do this so
again for the ram program restoring
active memory the vision and goal is to
develop neuroprosthetics for memory
recovery in human subjects living with
this kind of injury now
the ramp program is interesting because
this is darpa's is not our first uh
foray into this
area of research we actually had a
predicate program called the remind
program where investigators showed in
animal subjects
that um
some aspects of memory could be recalled
so uh many of you may have heard of
ted berger and sam deadweiler they were
the investigators on this program again
doing fantastic kind of work in animal
subjects showing for uh delayed match to
sample kinds of paradigms that these
simple aspects of memory could be
facilitated through a closed-loop
neuroprosthetic device and that was even
under uh conditions of of
you know diminished um you know brain
functioning so like a brain injury so
again laid some these initial efforts
laid some of the foundations for you
know the hardware that could be used to
interface with the brain and the
algorithms that could be used to
interface with the brain as you can
imagine
to be able to kind of bridge an injury
for memory restoration we need to be
able to sense the signals from the brain
interpret them
and then deliver the specific neural
codes that are related to memory
function and this team again uh laid
some of the groundwork for that in this
remind program
um
again just kind of moving forward the
rand program is about thinking about
those aspects and more but in human
subjects so again now that we kind of
have a foundation for restoring memory
and animals others we thought it was a
great time to kind of pivot there
and start thinking about memory
restoration in humans now you know why
would we again want to make that pivot
point and there's a very interesting
point here
for animal subjects you can't ask them
what they are perceiving in terms of the
stimulation that's coming back in terms
of the memory function right so it gets
very important to do uh uh this kind of
memory research in human subjects where
they can ultimately report back to you
oh yes i'm perceiving a memory or no i
just have a again kind of a perception
of the elements of memory we don't know
yet so again now is a good time to be
kind of thinking about those in in
making some initial inroads
into this effort um some of the people
that are performing are working on the
uh the ram program um uh so sam
deadweight or ted berger are they do
have an effort on on the ram program
like to tell you about two other teams
that are working on the ram program so
we have one team
out of ucla it's led by itzhak freed
he's a neurosurgeon who's also been
working in the memory arena for many
years
and he's developing uh closed loop
neural prosthetics uh in conjunction
with lawrence livermore national
laboratories um uh for this endeavor um
we have another team at the university
of pennsylvania is being led by mike
kahana again one of the world's experts
in memory function uh you know the field
as an entirety uh he's working with
medtronic to develop a uh new memory
neuroprosthetic system uh for this so
just let me tell you a little bit about
you know both of their approaches
so you know overall in the ram program
the goal is to develop a fully
implantable neural prosthetic system
again that can sense interpret signals
from the brain and deliver precision
stimulation for memory formation and
recall
the study of memory is a very broad
field again many different types of
memory and we know that that's very
complex and challenging area
for the initial ram program we are just
looking at one type of memory
declarative memory this is memory about
facts
uh and and are trying to restore
declarative memory again in people that
are living uh with these kinds of
disorders so again the teams are going
to develop neuroprosthetic devices
they're going to develop a closed loop
neuro prosthetic experimental paradigms
uh for this and uh and demonstrate um
not only their understanding memory
formation and recall but also show how
that prosthetic system can be used in
that arena now again compared against
these two teams again we have ucla
sacred university of pennsylvania
michael honda that a little bit
different approaches to this so it's not
freed his focus is really in the
hippocampus and inter rhino cortex again
these are uh very specific areas that
are
involved in the formation
of memory
he's looking at specific types of
modulation of fields
of those neuronal firing patterns that
are involved in memory formation and
recall
and uh and we'll see how his approaches
ultimately pan out
um mike hahn at university of
pennsylvania has a little bit different
approach he's looking at more of the dis
distributed effects
of uh of memory formation and recall so
again we know that the hippocampus and
internal cortex is involved in this but
there are other structures of the brain
that are involved in more of the kind of
consolidation aspects and things like
that so he's taking more of a
distributed approach
to this problem the other really
interesting example or aspect of my
kahana's approach in all this is that
has multiple clinical centers across the
country where he'll be able to
again interact with a large cohort of
human subjects to understand some of
these fundamental fundamental aspects of
memory formation and recall so again
really looking forward to both of these
teams efforts uh just to give you some
background on where they are in their um
efforts uh the ram program started in
july of 2014.
so again we're you know getting close uh
you know to you know eight nine months
of effort on this and these teams are
already in human subjects gathering
their preliminary data developing their
initial devices and again starting their
uh initial analysis on all of that so
again really excited
uh for their work and so please stay
tuned for all of their efforts up moving
forward okay
now uh let's shift gears again here and
start talking about again the next step
in our brain function research portfolio
and let's move into this area i
described earlier about neuropsychiatric
illness okay
so again more complicated problem for
neuroprosthetic design uh and and one
that we're trying to develop the
technology for so
um
again neuropsychiatric illness is a very
difficult kind of problem and many
military personnel are are suffering
with these kinds of conditions and again
today
um you know the kinds of therapies that
we have ford is you know kind of talking
to your therapist prescribing drugs you
know maybe even having a deep brain
stimulation procedure for this uh but
again these are
again not very precise one of the goals
of the uh of our neurosci
neuroprosthetic efforts again just a
recap of the name this is the subnets
program
is to develop a device that can access
multiple sub uh cortical and subcortical
structures and then deliver precision
therapy to the circuits that are
involved in neuropsychiatric illness so
again we know in the brain that is
organized in a hierarchical structure we
know that there are multiple levels of
abstraction that may be involved in
neuropsychiatric illness and again today
we don't have the neurotechnology to
access all of those structures and even
kind of develop a closed neural
prosthetic for the kinds of things that
we are talking about
so the goal and the vision of the
subnets program is again to develop the
new understanding and new neural signal
modulation approach for these systems
based disorders and again we want to
really close the loop on these kinds of
therapies
we know that it's going to evolve maybe
four plus targets of the brain again the
technology doesn't exist to to get to
all of those uh so we are developing
technology to do that so let me tell you
a little bit about the teams uh that are
working on this project uh and and tell
you about their efforts moving forward
so the first team i like to describe is
at ucsf uh and it's led by edward chang
he's a neurosurgeon and uh he's teamed
up with a great uh group of
investigators that know not only basic
uh neurophysiology but also
computational neuroscience
he's teaming up with a small business
called cortera as well as a national
laboratory lawrence livermore national
lab to develop the next generation kind
of device that can again sense from
multiple structures of the brain
uh and on board in that device interpret
that information and then deliver uh
precision stimulation back to the brain
for treating those illnesses so again
fully implantable kind of medical device
for neuropsychiatric illness now one
very interesting aspect of the ucsf
team's approach to this is that they
have a hypothesis okay
that
neuropsychiatric illness
is a condition that uh you know is you
know potentially like evolved over time
okay in in each individual
and that by interacting with brain
circuits in an online and dynamic way
that
neuropsychiatric illness may be
potentially unlearned okay this is a
very profound kind of way of thinking
about neuropsychiatric illness and we
may be able to modulate brain circuits
in such a way that you can unlearn
neuropsychiatric illness
and they have a hypothesis that you know
there's a potential that if that is
indeed true
that while we may initially use a device
like this again to treat the
neuropsychiatric illness maybe some
point in the future that device may be
able to be removed
now again this is very far out kind of a
concept um and you know from darpa's
term we're willing to take a risk on
something like this because it's based
in a very interesting science and it may
work out it may not but along the way we
uh again really feel like we're going to
learn a lot about brain function we're
going to learn a lot about next
generation clinical therapies and a lot
about next generation kind of devices
that could ultimately be used to deliver
that kind of therapy so getting really
excited about that uh again we don't
know if it'll work but again willing to
take the chance on it to see what will
ultimately happen there
uh the second team that i'd like to uh
to tell you about is a team led by imod
escondar again another neuro or a
neurosurgeon again he's at mass general
hospital and has assembled a
a wonderful team of again
neuroscientists computational
neuroscientist as well as hardware
designers to address this problem so
he's teaming up um
with draper laboratories to develop the
hardware
for this kind of uh a problem and the
mgh team has also a very interesting
perspective on neuropsychiatric illness
and close new close-up neuroprosthetics
they have what's called a trans
diagnostic approach so again
neuropsychiatric illness involves many
different structures of the brain there
are many different comorbidities of
neuropsychiatric illness and there are
many different kind of behavioral
expressions
of neuropsychiatric illness and what he
seeks to do is that by using these
closed-loop kind of neural interfaces
can we find the intersections amongst
all of these three kind of axes
of um of neuropsychiatric illness again
traditionally when we think about these
illnesses you think of like that
clinical behavioral diagnostic but we
know that there's much more than that
there's neurophysiology that's involving
these circuits again the behavioral
expression and comorbidities it all
comes together they're trying to link
these aspects uh with their trans
diagnostic approach so again very early
on for both of these teams this project
actually just started in june of 2014
uh they are both both teams are already
in their human clinical tests they're
collecting their initial data sets doing
their initial analysis and developing
their first generation uh kind of
prototype devices so again extremely
excited about the work that's ongoing on
these programs and um you know between
both the ram and the subnets program you
know we we really feel like we're going
to be developing or capturing you know
one of the largest um you know uh um
collections of human uh neurophysiologic
uh kinds of data again we're gonna have
great insight into the brain into a wide
variety of conditions again really feel
like that's going to help
our understanding of brain function uh
moving into the future okay so uh those
are our uh two clinical uh programs that
are just getting started
i'd like to tell you about again the
last area of our brain function research
portfolio
and this is that foundational program
that i told you about called neurofast
neurofunction activity structure and
technology
again everything that i've told you up
to this point is based in
electrophysiology again
electrophysiology kind of dates back
right really to like 1700s
we know that there's a lot of
limitations on that electrophysiology
right you can only make observations of
brain activity but again if we think
back to the brain initiative and the
goals of the brain initiative is to
understand brain activity understand
brain structure and the behavior
associated uh you know in terms of the
output and the inputs of the brain so
ultimately what we want is all three
components together simultaneously and
awake behaving subjects and today we
don't necessarily have the technology to
do that so again at darpa we take a big
risk and big leap and we say can we
fundamentally change the way that we
interface with the brain and do this in
a really different way
and again we pivoted on that question
and and said look optical interfaces
with the brain are very interesting
maybe they have the right
characteristics to kind of solve this
problem
so in the neurofast program we have one
performer on that one team on that it's
made up of uh two very talented
investigators carl daiso roth and
krishna shannoy and what they have set
out to do is really combine uh things
like optogenetics
with calcium imaging uh with the clarity
process with closed loop brain machine
interfaces and by marrying all of those
aspects together again in awake and
behaving subjects they may be able to
have these kind of real-time
observations of brain structure
activity and behavior all together uh in
a very comprehensive data set and uh
it's it's remarkable the techniques that
this team is uh
is really rolling out uh the neuro fast
program started in uh january of 2014 so
again you know they've been working a
little bit longer and they've developed
some really remarkable kinds of
techniques they have you know real time
uh uh you know calcium reporters uh for
neural activity they're able to capture
in in optically in 3d volumes of tissue
over 800 cells simultaneously have again
real time time series readout from these
optical uh reporters
they have fast laser systems for again
traversing 3d volumes in order to
capture the again the 3d structure and
then they also have the right in
capabilities using optogenetic
techniques
in order to modulate those neurons so
full read write capacity
in this program using optical techniques
and getting awake behaving subjects and
again there's some phenomenal work
that's coming out of both of these
laboratories and you should see some of
those uh those results um
very near in the future
one of the great things about the neuro
fast program is that you know carl and
christian are really pushing the
envelope on this and at darpa we also
like to push the envelope and one of the
aspects that they're also working on in
in conjunction with this work that
they're doing in animal subjects it's
kind of like looking at
excise tissue from human brains and
applying these same kinds of techniques
and looking at 3d volumes of brain
tissue using not only these kind of fast
reporters but also looking at the
using the clarity process as well as
neural stimulation again to have some
really interesting preliminary results
from human neural tissue uh that we can
also in that arena bring together these
aspects again very challenging way out
there
but again these teams are willing to
really push the envelope and are making
great progress there so really excited
about the uh the neuro fast program so
um that's kind of an overview of
of our progress and our programs thus
far against spanning motor control
revolutionizing prosthetics program
memory function and the
restoring active memory or ram program
looking at neuropsychiatric illness and
brain function in the subnets program
and then foundational technologies for
new interfaces to the brain
uh in the neuro fast program the last
kind of couple thoughts that i'd like to
leave with the audience today
is that
um again you know we have a small set of
teams that are working on these these
projects but they are creating volumes
and volumes and volumes of data
associated with not only human but also
animal subjects
and one thing that we feel very strongly
on moving into the future again is that
kind of that social contract of their
taxpayers that are investing in this
kind of research again we're making a
big impact but again what's happening
with the data again how can we make the
most out of the data how can we leverage
our our expertise together in order to
again
make discoveries about the brain that
are not only in these primary
applications but even the secondary uh
applications and uh kind of the last
thing i like to do on on the
the presentation today is it give the
audience some provocations
on the social contract for neuroscience
research okay and again i'm just gonna
kind of throw these things out there for
the audience to think about and uh maybe
kind of take it back to your home
institutions or your laboratories or
wherever you may come from kind of think
about this moving forward so the first
uh provocation i'd like to throw out
there is um you know think about the
scale of the science that we're doing
and we're going after um some really big
problems here so the first com
provocation is when challenges are too
big for individuals to solve sharing of
data or sharing of techniques is not a
choice but a necessity again by the way
the darpa is kind of constructing our
projects we are kind of
requiring this and we contractually
requiring it again we would like to
think about this in the context of
broader portfolios and neuroscience
community about how we can change the
way that we actually do neuroscience
research okay and kind of take that idea
a step further
we really think like the idea of the
lone genius is becoming an increasingly
unrealistic and unproductive archetype
and
neuroscience research again the history
of neuroscience research is again
littered with you know the the lone
genius but again the scale and the kinds
of problems that we are addressing and
now and into the future i don't know if
that model is really going to hold so
again thinking about some uh really new
and interesting ways of uh dealing with
that
uh another aspect that we feel is very
interesting is uh you know the upcoming
generation of uh scientists uh is really
ready for a more open and collaborative
approach but the domain conditions
really are not there yet right so again
young scientists you know young
investigators say you're living in a
culture of you know sharing and you know
social media and things like that so
again the kind of stage is set and the
stage is primed uh but in the the
research arena particularly the
neuroscience arena i don't know if we
have all of the uh the tools or
conditions to make that happen so again
there may be some opportunities there
you know into the future
so you know again next
kind of provocation here is data sharing
can support collaboration but we feel
that sharing alone is not the primary
driver again there's a lot of uh aspects
that go into how we conduct neuroscience
research and the tools that are there uh
to support that next generation or next
kind of
uh ways of doing neuroscience research
into the future so again we're very
proactive to think creatively
about these aspects
in the future
um
next provocation again for uh sharing to
become a priority collaboration must
receive meaningful recognition and
rewards so here's another thing so again
prior to my time at darpa i was an
academic researcher again i've been
through the gauntlet of the 10-year
promotion process so you know i know at
many universities uh across the us as
well as internationally
that you know for 10-year promotion data
sharing and doing science in this way
may not be a priority but again to
address the problems that were really
interested in the future and to really
live up to that social contract maybe it
should be part of that uh tenure and
promotion process so again a provocation
for all of those people that are sitting
on those panels
and thinking about those aspects uh
again moving into the future and again
if we do want to change uh some of those
aspects uh you know we should give
incentives for sharing rewarding teams
and not individuals or maybe uh you know
give incentives for sharing by measuring
impact not just publication so again um
you know
a lot of people think of like
publications and impact factors but what
i'm talking about here is not
necessarily just that is the impact of
neuroscience research on you know
quality of life or
medicine in general again thinking about
the brain initiative as a whole and how
our scientific
contributions can really elevate
all of those kinds of uh of efforts okay
so again the kind of the last
provocation uh that i'd like to leave
with the uh the audience here is that
deliberate growth of a new generation of
hybrid players uh will accelerate
progress again maybe true maybe not true
i don't know but uh it's something that
darpa is very interested in learning
more about this kind of hybrid players
in this new space here and uh very
interested in learning about new ideas
from the community and kind of fostering
those moving into the future
so with that i'd just like to say thank
you to everybody for uh to listening in
on this webcast and uh would like to
open up the floor if anybody has
questions and the moderators can uh you
know again give some feedback on on how
to submit those questions through the
online system thank you very much
thank you dr sanchez for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session as you said i would like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the q a box which can be
found by clicking on the green q a
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we'll try to
answer as many questions
as we can
one question here um one question oh
hang on let me uh all right um it says
here the military as a rule does not
enlist people with adhd and yet as a few
years ago the prevalence of adhd is much
higher in the military are you working
on answers for this area
um
so
in the programs that i just described we
are not working on adhd
um you know there are many different
branches of the dod
that are looking at a wide variety of
neurologic or neuropsychiatric kind of
disorders
some of those may be working on this
area but again within darpa's purview
we're not specifically working on that
particular uh problem so thank you so
much for uh for that question
any others moving forward
great
thank you dr sanchez for that answer
can you tell us a bit more about the
target patient population for traumatic
brain injury and memory project is there
a typical
neuroanatomical profile
to these patients
so uh so that's a fantastic question um
traumatic brain injury is a extremely uh
difficult problem and even just a
diagnosis of traumatic brain injury
right so we have these very loose terms
again the medical community like mild
moderate severe traumatic brain injury
um you know the nature of these injuries
is very
diverse
everybody is very different so
we don't right now have a target
population uh
for this
um along the way what one of our goals
is is to again try to characterize the
types of injuries each individual may or
may not have
and um
and then put the therapy that we are
developing at closed loop therapy in the
context of that
so uh so yeah this is a huge challenge
and you know one that you know we don't
have an answer for right now but are
going to try to characterize and come up
with very precise uh approach to it
moving forward into the future so again
kind of mild moderate or severe
is not good enough moving forward into
the future so again thank you so much
for that question
great thank you for that answer dr
sanchez
traumatic brain injury is a huge deal in
the military and i i know many of our
service members are suffering with that
so so thank you so much uh everybody for
attending again some fantastic questions
here again this is an unbelievable
opportunity for neuroscience and
neurotechnology and to have a
president's brain initiative uh in
uh you know
as as the kind of forefront of these
efforts is just remarkable and again
we're working really hard in order to
deliver upon the promise of of that
effort and that that initiative and it's
really a all hands-on debt kind of
approach so um we look forward to uh to
great progress on this so please stay
tuned and again thank you so much
participating in this event and uh
and again
we need to solve these problems and have
to work really hard to do so so thank
you so much for your attention
thank you dr sanchez for that
presentation i want to also thank the
audience for their interesting questions
and participation in today's event
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for the next few
months you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay and we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you again for your attention see
you next time goodbye